aquí tenemos un prisma rectangular que
tiene la forma de un ladrillo o de una
pecera de cristal este prisma
rectangular está hecho de cubos
unitarios los cuales miden cada uno un
cuarto de pie por un cuarto de pie por
un cuarto de pie aquí lo podemos dibujar
este es el comunitario que mide un
cuarto de pie por un cuarto de pie por
un cuarto de pie es decir tiene un largo
de un cuarto de pie por un alto de un
cuarto de pie por un ancho un cuarto de
pie o podrías decir que este es el largo
eso no importa dado eso cuál es el
volumen que tiene este prisma
rectangular supongo que ya lo intentaste
por tu cuenta hay un par de maneras de
ver esto
la primera es calcular el volumen de
cada uno de estos cubos unitarios y ver
entonces cuántos cubos hay en el prisma
hagamos eso el volumen del comunitario
es un cuarto de pie
por un cuarto de pie
por un cuarto de pie y esto a que es
igual esto es igual a un cuarto por un
cuarto por un cuarto y las unidades son
pies cúbicos que se escribe como pies
elevado a la 3 y esto es igual a un
cuarto por un cuarto es un dieciseisavo
y por un cuarto esto es igual a un 64 de
pie cúbico ese es el volumen de cada uno
de los cubos unitarios
ese es el volumen de cada uno de estos
cubos y cuántos cubos hay cuántos de
esos cubos unitarios hay aquí bueno
podemos ver que hay dos capas de esos
cubos aquí tenemos uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho cubos en esta capa
superior y abajo tenemos otros tantos
así es que tenemos ocho por dos tenemos
16 de esos cubos unitarios por lo cual
el volumen de todo el prisma rectangular
va a ser 16 por el volumen de cada
comunitario que existe
164 ambos pies cúbicos y esto es igual a
16 sobre 64
pies cúbicos y 16 sobre 64 es igual a un
cuarto dividiendo el numerador el
denominador entre 16 nos da un cuarto de
pie cúbico y ese es el volumen del
prisma rectangular la segunda manera de
hacer esto es tomar las dimensiones de
este prisma el largo el ancho y el alto
y hacer el producto vamos a calcularlo
así tenemos que el ancho es 2 por un
cuarto que es igual a un medio de pie
vayamos ahora a la altura la altura del
prisma es 2 por un cuarto que también es
un medio de pie 2 por un cuarto es un
medio de pie y finalmente cuánto tiene
de largo este prisma rectangular el
largo es 44 por un cuarto de pie que es
igual a cuatro cuartos de pie que es
igual a un pie y ahora podemos calcular
el volumen como
el largo
por el ancho
largo por ancho por alto por alto y
estos puntos que tenemos aquí no son
puntos decimales están a una altura
superior éstos indican multiplicaciones
desde ponerlos como una equis lo ponemos
como un punto entonces cuánto es el
largo del largo ya calculamos que es uno
el ancho ya calculamos que es un medio y
el alto que también calculamos que es
un medio déjame ponerlo con el color
adecuado un medio esto es uno por un
medio por un medio esto es un cuarto
esto es
cuarto y aquí tenemos pie por pie por
pie esto es un cuarto de pie cúbico
hemos obtenido que el volumen del prisma
es un cuarto del pie cúbico exactamente
el mismo resultado que habíamos obtenido
antes excelente